and your first draft if Kelly Winston
Jones was written when uh several years
ago III had been thinking I had been
coming up with the idea i actually was I
can remember exactly where I was I was
in innovative artists so i think i was
there in two thousand five and six so
we're looking at you know six years ago
now and when i came up with the original
concept and i was sitting at my desk i
was assisting an agent at the time and i
was reading the trades which i recommend
any writer should always be reading the
trades by the way because you should
know what projects are selling what
studios are making what what production
companies are making what you should
always know all about the business so
read the trades on a daily basis whether
that's variety or Hollywood Reporter or
deadlines wherever your outlet is go to
those and read them and be familiarized
with the industry and especially with
the genre that you write in and the
projects that you're trying to get off
the ground but I was reading the trades
and there was an entire article about an
actress who had just recently passed
away and she was an award winner an
Academy Award winner big awards from the
50s I want to say and I went to UC Santa
Barbara I was a film student I studied
film history and film theory I've seen
almost every movie out there and for
some reason i did not know who this
actress was and i was thinking to myself
what do you have to do these days to
leave a legacy because in the 50s or 60s
this actress was probably a household
name and really well known and people
would fill the theaters to see her and I
didn't know who she was and so based on
that idea of what you have to do to
leave a legacy that will actually
withstand time got me into thinking well
what would you do to even just leave a
small legacy and so killing Winston
Jones is the story about a you know a PE
teacher a retired PE teacher in a small
town that finds out they're building a
new gymnasium at the school that he
taught at his entire life and he
desperately wants to get this gym named
after him the only problem is that the
prince
who was an ex-student of his that didn't
really like him too much you know
decides he doesn't want to name it after
him and he wants to name it memoriam so
the PE teacher who is played by Richard
Dreyfuss has to decide if it's worth
ending his own life to get this named
after him and in memoriam to leave a
legacy to leave a piece of himself
behind so that's where the original
concept and idea came up and I worked it
and reworked it and wrote draft after
draft for you know a couple years I
think before I gave it to you know
eventually Joel and the rest of the
people that became attached
you